[Musique]
selon certaines études elle serait la
préoccupation première des martiniquais
au même rang que de chômage
la délinquance dans l'île mais son
omniprésence conduit parfois à sa
banalisation ou à une forme de fatalisme
pourtant les chiffres ne mentent pas la
martinique se classe 4ème région de
france la plus violente et les faits
commis avec arme
ils sont dix fois plus élevé que dans
l'hexagone une violence que certains
n'hésitent pas à mettre en scène de
manière décomplexée et valorisante
des fictions servant sur un plateau
d'argent de mise au code aux jeunes
cerveaux en formation mais les maisons
encore les conséquences souvent tragique
est bien réelle